come on hey you guys we decided to do
one of our matinee shows cuz like I said
you know we're doing matinee shows every
day and all this other kind of stuff so
Tom's like well why don't we just do
this one live because people seem to
like the live streams yeah it seems to
be live right now I don't know if it
really the last live stream that we did
the program defaulted back to internal
microphone on the laptop so it sounded
kind of yeah but we made sure to send it
back over to our better quality
microphone yeah it's like I don't know
why it keeps defaulting saw a pretty
good arm Australian flick last night
yeah I'll back yes based on a true case
of some dumbass Americans and get lost
out in the [ __ ] outback one dumbass
was getting ready I'm not gonna [ __ ]
cuz he's dead and [ __ ] but he did some
stupid ass [ __ ] and that cost him his
life in a survival situation and this
might be a movie that a person might
want to see yeah I mean to learn
something about how do they run it down
he was getting ready to go off to the
army but he didn't even have basic
training and he made a lot of mistakes
that [ __ ] army basic training even
for infantry would have you know
AIT or infantry AIT would solve a lot of
this guy's problem well I I should say
too that it's like I've never even been
in the military or anything like that
and even I was just like dude what are
you doing even I know better than that
just from watching Bear Grylls and I
shouldn't be alive so it's turned this
this movie is it what I liked about it
is that the movie was very a pure it was
a pure movie yeah hey Nico oh hey don't
need it was a pure movie it just told
the damn story and it was very linear in
the way that it did it and it was fun it
was kind of like watching an episode of
I shouldn't be alive
it really did seem like too long it
didn't overstay its welcome it was
exciting
especially once they got a law and you
no don't do that no do what do you
[ __ ] thank you I don't know if I
should spoil it okay now here's the
thing know what I was gonna say okay so
this movie is called out back like I
said now I'm not gonna call it because
what I thought you know the trailer and
everything like that I was thinking it
was gonna go more in like a Wolf Creek
kind of direction
you know if the classic Australian
serial killer one that I think was a
little bit based on Ivan Milat but the
backpacker killer this is not that this
is basically just like a straight-up
survival horror movie I would actually
call it a survival drama yeah more than
a horror movie yeah because it's
actually just fake you know based around
these two characters and their
relationship and their decisions and
stuff that they do now okay the thing
about it I've seen two different posters
for this movie one of them said based on
a true story one of them said based on
an urban legend when you see the movie
it says that it's a true story but that
it became an urban legend so I was very
curious to see like what exactly
happened in the story to see like how
close the movie was to what actually
happened now I'm not saying that it
didn't really happen but I couldn't find
a real case because they said it
happened in 2015 I couldn't find a real
case you know at least in the first five
or six pages of google searching that
that was like this there have been cases
of people that were rescued after you
know a long time there was one like
older guy who was rescued after two days
he didn't have any shoes or any water or
anything like that he was rescued in the
outback there was one guy actually there
was one guy and it was two older women
and they were driving across the outback
and their car got stuck and they were
like trying to get out and then they
were like going for help and everything
like that and they were out there for
two weeks and they did actually I
believe they found two of them they
haven't found the third one yet they
found the two of them alive and they
were mostly okay
they didn't seem to do anything super
dumb and they actually did find a water
source and like you know filtered things
through shirts and you know boil it and
things like that if you're into
watersports you'd like to suck in movies
I was just going to say that a peach
there's a lot of Pedro
so if that's gonna bother you then do
not watch this because pretty much the
whole second act of the movie here he
goes he's drinking more beer it's
[ __ ] stupid okay
I mean you you're told that early on in
military training that it's actually
better just to get rid of it do not
[ __ ] read wrink your [ __ ] pee it's
toxic it just puts more yes dress puts
more stress on your kidneys it's like
drinking salt water yeah suck out those
hammies don't do that it either it
accelerates it accelerates the problems
associated with [ __ ] rehydration
dehydration yeah so not a good idea not
unless you have the equipment to
properly filter [ __ ] that [ __ ] and
filter and it would be tough because
there's a lot of ammonia is a lot of
chemicals that had to be separated right
on it to get the water back out of the
year so it's usually not something you
can do with him as man-portable um so
just don't drink it man find a water
source there are ways to find water even
in the desert you can find water well
yeah and I mean according to this movie
like I said and I'm not saying that this
isn't based on true story it was just
like nothing that I could find that was
exactly the same as this but if indeed
this was based on a true story they did
find her after what was it five days or
six days and she had survived yes she
did drink some of the dudes pee but also
she was mostly getting water from like
Dew in the morning she would like
squeeze it off the you know trees and
everything like that got a big sheet of
plastic that could help you yeah you
won't you look you're gonna be thirsty
the whole time so you might be like I'm
gonna tell you know you might die but
being able to collect do and [ __ ] like
that um might buy you a couple of extra
days well yeah and I mean honestly
that's gonna be better than nothing and
it's like so if you have like a large
thing like you said that you can like
collect fur do to collect on so
basically okay so what the premise of
this movie is I'm gonna say this movie
actually kind of reminded me somatically
oh thank you very much Matt thank you
but uh this movie actually kind of
reminded me a little bit and I don't
know I don't think we reviewed it
because it's you know not super new I
might have mentioned in our Halloween
show when I was you know
recommending horror movies it reminded
me of the movie back country which was
like a 2014 Canadian movie the one about
and that's kind of based on true story -
about like a couple that go out hiking
in the woods and then they get lost and
they get stalked by like a killer bear
and like he gets like eaten by the bear
and everything like that this kind of
reminded me a little bit of that and
then it was even like a whole marriage
proposal angle which this does as well
which that kind of made me sleep the
thing about I did like this movie but I
did feel like I think it would have
benefited a little bit for making the
characters a little bit more likable um
because yeah I feel like you know she
was she kind of like you know got her
[ __ ] together like as it went on but she
was kind of like annoying at the
beginning he seemed like really mopey at
the because she had turned down his
proposal like on the plane over there
they were going like on vacation to you
know drive cross-country against us
across Australia and so he had asked her
to marry him on the plane on the way
over and she had said no apparently in
front of everybody so he was like super
bummed out and super mopey and pissed
off at her like through the whole time
so you know even though you can
understand if you were in that situation
that yeah you'd probably be pissed off
about that
it doesn't make like a good watch cuz
you were just kind of like dude you know
you're in Australia you paid for this
vacation it's like it lazy and now you
don't want to do anything you just want
to mope around to be pissed and I'm not
sure these are actual Australians either
I'm gonna tell you that the characters
weren't written by an American he sees
me I'm not sure there are actual
Americans because I know the characters
weren't [ __ ] written by Americans
they just they sounded like American
stereotypes stereotypes of Americans to
me well that doesn't necessarily mean
that an American that are right though I
don't think so though I'm just saying I
think it was nice I think those are
Australian actors acting like Americans
because the girls character I didn't buy
it you know she came off as a super
over-the-top kind of mainstream bro
chick yeah my mom yeah and you know like
being very false happy and fakie and
[ __ ] you know which there is she was
kind of like shallow but I don't there's
a lot of American chicks are like that
yeah so that's why I guess it didn't
bother
she was annoying as [ __ ] yeah but I had
to pick the most stereotypical type yeah
yeah which the average person I don't
think is like that
well MIT was just the Ariston we don't
run into his like that maybe they are
like that that's what I'm saying maybe
they are like that we just don't hang
out with people like that because
they're annoying issues yeah so maybe
that's why but so you know like I said I
should say that it's not a horror horror
movie this is basically just like you
know they go out there and you know it
kind of seems like doomed from the
beginning because he's like all mopey
and everything and then she finally like
cajoles him into light let's go swimming
at the beach and everything like that
then of course he gets you know bit by a
jellyfish like stung by a jellyfish and
then so it seemed like it was partially
like her fault at the beginning yeah but
then he starts making like the series of
like really stupid decisions like what
will one they're like okay well we're
gonna drive out to Ayers Rock which I
guess is called I can't remember what
it's called now but it goes now by it's
a you know tribal name hold on one
second what makes somebody administrator
get rid of those box don't make me go
full coppercab what's up with all those
links that's not a link okay that's
that's your I can't see it from here who
is it that's Mexico talk just you know
right go ahead I'm almost gonna go
[ __ ] straight copper you guys know
crap just go screaming over things you
know the trolls not welcome please don't
do that my ear is right here buddy say
anything important you think we have to
redress any questions well I'm just yeah
somebody said that a back country was
good yeah that was a good movie I like
to backcountry a lot more this one but
um this one like I said so so he gets
stung by a jellyfish and then they
decide they're gonna drive out to Ayers
Rock which is like a 32 hour drive from
wherever it as they are and so they
start driving out there they have a GPS
they have stuff and it's like you know
they have extra gas and they have water
and [ __ ] like that but then like the GPS
starts to go awry and it kind of starts
leading them around in circles because
basically they're out in the outback and
it's like dirt roads it's not paved
roads anymore and there's like nobody
out there so rather than doing the smart
thing and being like hey [ __ ] this let's
just turn around and go back the way we
came because I mean essentially it's
only like one
Road once the GPS starts like running
your own in circles
he's decides he's gonna pull over and
then he's like okay well let's hike up
to this Ridge big mistake and then we'll
look up and he and his leg is [ __ ] up
and everything like that so he's like
and then when we come back you know then
if we don't see anything then we'll turn
around go back except the problem is
that when they hike out to the ridge it
takes it's farther away than they
thought it takes longer than they
thought because his leg is all [ __ ] up
some starts going it's the Sun starts
going down it gets dark and they'd
completely lose their sense of direction
because it's completely pitch black they
don't know where the car is they [ __ ]
lose the car and so now they're just
like wandering around in circles and
have no idea where they are they're
running out of water
they don't have any food and and his leg
is getting infected and all this other
kind of [ __ ] and of course you have like
it's Australia so you have like
scorpions poisonous snakes everything
and he made it to [ __ ] AIT in the
army he would have gotten basic land
navigation course which tells you right
there not to [ __ ] count on [ __ ] like
that never leave anything like your car
without a [ __ ] compass or a map you
just don't do that [ __ ] well in another
song another stupid thing that he did
was that you find out later on is that
he left the [ __ ] car headlights on
they already had fuel they had air
conditioner they had all kinds of [ __ ]
there's no reason to leave the car they
should have just drove back the way they
[ __ ] came well see they should have
been champion could have got her back to
the damn road right and like I said it
wasn't like there was like a million
different road she could pick from it
it's just like just turns on it I mean
if if he had just done that from the
very beginning instead of like just
thinking he knew where he was I'm not
lost we have a GPS we have this you know
it's like the these types of dudes that
they put in these movies and it's like I
know what I'm doing I know where I am I
can't possibly be lost you know they
don't and even she's the whole time it's
like can we please just go back can we
please not like do that but he just like
keeps on pressing on and such like in
male stereotype man it's [ __ ] sexism
yeah I never get lost because I never
get lost they get lost well also I think
they put it in movies too
just because it it's really device it's
a plot device it raises conflict it's
kinda like the girl sees the ghost first
that's exactly what and the guy doesn't
believe so much so that like when I see
a movie that subverts that trope I'm
always like pleasantly surprised be a
lot better if the man sees the ghost and
the women goes you're full of [ __ ] man
get off those meds have we ever seen one
like that it should be I don't think
that I've ever seen no I mean please
correct me if I'm wrong I'm sure must
have seen one but there had to have been
one movie where the dude sees the ghost
of the woman doesn't believe him
and just think was a medieval horror I
thinks he's nuts was a medieval like
that you know well maybe he was losing
it I was losing it but I think she was
Kanu knew that the house was [ __ ] up
yeah I think they kind of both came to a
decision and evil was a great movie back
when you when we were young it didn't
age well it looks like a made-for-tv
movie now it's just not I'd like to get
it on blu-ray though yeah I don't have
affection for it it's not like it's not
objectively a very good movie but for
some reason there's like always
something there's some kind of style
nostalgia about it because I saw it when
I was a kid she's not scary no to me
when I was little yeah when I was like
eight I liked the evil was a lot more
scarier today that's true that was a
good one yeah there's sinking down into
the damn sand and people getting
electrocuted in [ __ ] girl getting her
[ __ ] clothes torn off by the
invisible ghosts and [ __ ] yeah yeah
pervy ass invisible well you know it's
like if there really are ghosts you know
some of a certain percentage of them
yeah any comments needs to be addressed
we had the shining Paranormal Activity
all hail and Lorraine Warren lol yeah
yeah yeah ever see people are just like
making jokes yeah sounds like I
shouldn't be a live episode yeah that's
exactly what we said yeah it's it's
essentially like that cuz I love that
show um I think the ones that scare me
the most are the ones where people like
in show Rex and they're like trapped in
the ocean because I'm like
like I'm not saying that it's like I
shouldn't be alive episode I think it's
$5.99 on [ __ ] Xbox one I think it was
$5.99 it's it you can kill some time
watch and it's a decent movie yes I
think it was an hour 25 minutes so it's
not like super long or anything like I
said if any of you can find like the
actual news story supposedly this was
based on or if they just completely
pulled it out of their ass like I said I
don't think they completely pulled it
out of their ass because there have been
other stories like this but the whole
thing about them being a couple and they
were highschool sweethearts and the
whole marriage proposal thing and then
you know the exact way that it happened
I couldn't find a news story like that
even though I did find several other
news stories about people that did get
lost in the outback and were found later
on like after like I said two days two
weeks whatever and some of them were
found but none of them it wasn't like at
the exact same situation so maybe it was
kind of a thing where it was like an
amalgamation of several different cases
I'm not really sure but um you know and
like I said don't be expecting anything
like super gory like wolfcreek none or
anything you know super um you know
action-packed or anything this basically
I would call it a survival drama is what
it is it's basically these two against
the environment and the dude is a
perfect example of not what to [ __ ]
do do not do with this dude [ __ ] no
especially not nice like drinking your
pee but it gets worse than that when you
see this dude do this [ __ ] you got what
the [ __ ] are you doing and I was like
dude dude why would you even do that why
I don't I can't I can't see him I can't
see a person actually doing that yeah
that was one thing that kind of made me
feel like maybe this isn't like man
entirely true story because it's like I
have a feeling that he tries to drink
something that's not a drinkable okay
that you should not eat and he's trying
to convert it into piss to give to her
yeah
and you're like dude what the [ __ ] you
thinking it's like yeah I don't know
that that was the main I mean some of
the other decisions he made were dumb
but not so dumb that you just wanted to
like punch him in the dick or anything
but that decision I was just kind of
like oh
it's like everybody knows that you can't
drink that that too then to drink that
you know what I mean it's like please
don't it's drinking this somebody says
drinking pee makes nice skin yeah I
think there's some [ __ ] there's all
kinds of [ __ ] weird [ __ ] because
whiten your teeth there's some [ __ ]
there's middle-eastern [ __ ] things
about drinking camel urine that come
from the [ __ ] Quran and then some of
these guys actually did drink [ __ ]
human piss for certain medicinal things
and that's [ __ ] like that might go on in
places like China with herbal medicine
the Chinese do some weird [ __ ] I didn't
know it but you know the Chinese are
cannibals they've been cannibals for a
[ __ ] long time a lot of people like
what the [ __ ] you talking about just go
on go go and go Chinese cannibalism and
search and you'll [ __ ] see that up
and even up until the late 80s there was
cannibalism going on for political
reasons it would eat enemies I think he
brought that he's called flesh banquets
it's [ __ ] weird man and recently they
found like children's arms that were had
been cooked in ginger and [ __ ] chili
dad there's no taboo for it there it
doesn't necessarily mean that they
killed the person to eat them all the
time but if they get their hands on a
dead person just laying around going
yeah he's evidently uh and it has to do
with Chinese medicine sometimes and
Chinese medicine involves all kinds of
weird [ __ ] the thing about this one that
that I actually kind of liked like I
said if you're not like into watching
pee drinking you might want to skip this
one because there's a lot of pee
drinking going on of this the whole time
I was watching it because I have a hard
time people watching Bear Grylls like
drinking pee and stuff like that because
I've because that's really big
apparently um even though this so put
this one I had to like fake and be like
it's just apple juice it's just apple
juice it's just stuff because otherwise
I would just gag well I was watching
that curse is me out so much but there
is one thing that I liked about this
with the pee drinking is that they kind
of like foreshadow it like earlier on
because he was like making jokes about
drinking pee like when they first
started getting lost when they weren't
really taking it seriously it's like oh
we'll find the car in a minute whatever
and she was just like man you know I
don't know how thirsty
I'm not drinking your [ __ ] pee or
whatever and I liked that when they get
to that point she's just like it takes
her a really really long time dude she's
like I don't know if I could do this and
even at this boys it's been like four or
five days that she has her people
honored even then she's just like yeah I
just I don't know it's like gently I
mean if this does not help you okay I
have to explain this to people but ya
think it's ridiculous if you're [ __ ]
this severely dehydrated and you're
pissed and and that's just dark [ __ ]
yellow or brown socks that's how that's
how you know you rehydrate yeah yeah now
if you're like in the army where they
were constantly [ __ ] force feeding
this water because to try to prevent
[ __ ] dehydration and [ __ ] you could
just piss and be clear you could
probably shrink down there wouldn't be
much in there you could probably drink
that again and it would taste bad but it
probably wouldn't be good it's like hey
why would you why would you because
you've got enough water here that's
right exactly you're obviously too
hydrated to read wrink that ok so right
it's not useful in a survival situation
yeah in a survival situation where you
don't have water [ __ ] you're gonna
[ __ ] dehydrate quickly when you piss
that shit's gonna be [ __ ] brown that's
toxic yeah put that back in the system
would be worse than not drinking can't
imagine that it would smell I mean like
regular pee smells worse like bad enough
but yeah when you're like dehydrated
like pee it smells worse and worse yeah
and the reason it smells worse worse is
because it has more and more toxic
chemical ah'd a little [ __ ] dead blood
cells in it [ __ ] like [ __ ] chemicals
like ammonia and crap there's not much
water in it yeah it's just like I
honestly I I don't know if I can say
like in if I was in a situation like
this woman was in but I think I'd
probably just if you died I'd rather
just die if you were to guess that and
filter it through a brutal water filter
it would probably come out clear but if
you were to [ __ ] drink that it'd
probably just be on drinkable I don't
think you'd be able to separate all the
other Bowl I know that's a lawyer
watching it wouldn't be much water in it
it would probably be some con toxic [ __ ]
like I said ammonia and [ __ ] weird
stuff I don't know what else made when
we were watching the movie last night we
were
that's like whether if you ran it
through a waiter yeah but how many times
we have to run it I'm not buying another
Brita so that we should I'm sure they
got some water sports [ __ ] people
tasted like well because remember wasn't
there um what is that [ __ ] show that
you see on TLC or my strange addiction
right yeah there was a couple pee
drinkers I totally admit [ __ ] yeah there
was at least one pee drink around there
and I couldn't watch Jesus like no crazy
ass woman yeah it was a crazy woman
drinking her own pee yeah yeah yeah
that's right [ __ ] weird and then
there's a whole series of the black
girls at eight white powder that was
some weird [ __ ] remember that it was
Christmas Day consistently overweight
black girls eating chalk white chalk
eating [ __ ] talcum powder and eating
drywall yeah it was some weird [ __ ]
there was some was that was it
mayonnaise or no it wasn't mayonnaise it
was a tartar sauce
I don't know ranch dressing yeah there's
a bunch it was something like that it
was like some white goopy I thought it
was tartar sauce but I could be wrong
about I mean I'm not gonna lie it's
harder sauce is siliceous but but she
was inhaling and snort and [ __ ] [ __ ]
tons of damn powder new powder the weird
thing about that show is that the weird
thing about that weird will say what if
you say Bear Grylls enters the check
right it's like I think he's being a
little irresponsible Barry Bear Grylls
telling everybody I think he just likes
drinking pee and he just wanted me that
is he's that guy he's that survivalist
guy I don't know if he's on TV anymore
pride full of [ __ ] but um yeah the army
would say never do that is it safer to
drink someone else's that's actually I
doubt it it might be worse yes yeah
melted hot butter popcorn pee yeah from
everything that [ __ ] I ever heard
through all the [ __ ] training in the
infantry which is all influenced by
Special Forces trainings which is the
extremes of survival you were better to
become dehydrated than to read wrink
your own [ __ ] urine that it
exacerbated the problem yeah that's
better to just die from the D hide in
other words your survival time starts
declining when you do that so you'll
just die faster yeah they're just not to
to do it at all
it's a that's what I mean it's like I'd
rather just I'm sure it's really
unpleasant to die of dehydration but but
then on top of that having to drink pee
also which is like that's like adding
yes adding another you're adding pours
layer of unpleasantness may not be that
bad if you were super super super super
hydrated in the early P that came out of
you was clear earlier the early thing on
me I'm [ __ ] making up terms make up a
whole drinking system if you got some of
that for his generation prolly wouldn't
be that bad but that's not gonna be the
piss that you're having when you're
dehydrated right exactly
it's gonna be that [ __ ] brown ham
slice smellin [ __ ] piece yeah like it
like it'll smell like ham slice and
[ __ ] cabbage thank you again oh thank
you very much that's right keep them
greenbacks flowing yeah I gave it on
Facebook and Instagram and everything so
at least people would have a half hour
like yeah this this show was gonna go up
today anyway so yeah let's just do it
[ __ ] live yeah it'll go up faster and
then once we close this one out we got
to record another one that's gonna go up
Lin uh Friday Friday okay actually go
Thursday for patrons and Friday for
everyone else pissing with Tom that'll
be the nude sideshow yeah if you're if
you're in a survival situation don't do
that
look if you're gonna go on any long trip
where you think you're gonna be in an
area that might be slightly deserted
pack a [ __ ] pack seriously I would
never and food and fuelled [ __ ] you know
because I would always I would always
assume the worst like if you were gonna
drive across the abbey which I'm not
gonna do that but if I was gonna do that
like if I had to do that for whatever
reason I would take every [ __ ] thing
I could say I got more of it
we packed [ __ ] rucksacks in my
[ __ ] in my [ __ ] loadout all right
each one of those can support a person
for about seven days okay so I can
support three people for seven days at a
moment's notice
why well look what's going on that's one
thing but there but really for Florida
hurricanes yeah it's good to have that
kind of stuff use again in the
summertime like um you know kind of by
the wayside in case like at or you know
in hurricanes like small tornadoes and
it's like if your house floods and you
can't stay there it's like you know
power lines are down all the other kind
of [ __ ] I could take those three packs
and throw it into a trunk of a [ __ ]
vehicle and footage and Jayco hell out
and for a week three support three
people already no problem now during
that week you're also building stuff and
[ __ ] if you putting out rot lines and
whatever for fishing and trapping it's
that way you know but you have a
seven-day buffer to get everything set
up and running yeah that's how it's
worth that's how you do it and if it's
only two people then you know you've
added and you got every day if it's only
one person then it's [ __ ] you got three
weeks for the [ __ ] then all the Pens
just luxury yeah
yes Miller says where else can you
discuss drinking pee at 2:30 p.m. on a
Monday but now so the business movie
says I was in the army and they told us
if we had no water you can drink your
pee once what but don't do what the dude
and this one he said Bernie's like he's
burning what I said
yeah that first generation clear sleep
might buy you a little bit more time but
in general [ __ ] do anyway like I said
I'd have to be especially if it was that
[ __ ] a ham slice piss and it [ __ ] in
this [ __ ] vapors coming off of it
like a gasoline like a little pig Vince
wines go monkey waves yeah so yeah if
you're into Australian survival horror
this is actually a pretty decent movie
like I said it's more a drama than a
horror movie and it's not there's
nothing supernatural there's no serial
killers there's no nothing like that
it's just like mostly like attacks of
little
and you know exposure and dehydration
and things like that so if that sounds
like something you'd be into cause 5
bucks 99 on Xbox I don't know if it's
I'm sure you can run at other places
YouTube or Amazon Prime or whatever so
you know I'm like I said it's not that
long it's only an hour and 25 minutes so
it didn't overstay its welcome yeah it
was it pretty moved along at a pretty
good clip and you know like I said you
you can watch it'll like talk about hood
down the dude is and it's like what you
would do in that situation and you know
how I would not even had good music get
myself into that situation in the first
place but it had a good soundtrack on it
and the Edit was was kind of fast-paced
I liked it yeah yeah it was decent so
yeah like I said it's not as good as I
didn't like it as much as backcountry
even though it kind of reminded me of
that like at some points but it's still
a decent watch so you want to end into
the stream yeah go ahead so I can
because I need to record any comments
have to be addressed or anything um
let's see she says oh sunder says there
was a shouldn't be a live episode with a
guy and his daughter who got lost in the
australian wild they had 4 spare tires
and water and they still almost died ok
yeah so it's like even when you take
[ __ ] with you I think people don't
realize like the outback is very very
large and very very empty and you know
there's all kinds of like [ __ ]
poisonous creatures that are there has
come into play in this movie but there
are also guys that are survival experts
about the outback and they can live out
there like the Bushmen yea because some
people do live out there there are ways
to live out to survive it yes there are
but it's like you have to know what
you're doing you can't just be like oh
I'm a tourist and it's like I have some
jerky and one thing that water and like
a more extreme it is the the the the
more extreme the environment they're
less forgiving it is like you know
desert or very high altitude mountains
one wrong one wrong move you can you can
die you have a bad day you could die
yeah yeah somebody also recommended a
movie called killing ground from 2016
which I do not think I've seen but uh
you know that's so I guess that's like
another survival horror so I'm gonna
have to check that out so we will see
you guys again trip will either do
another livestream tomorrow or I might
do another matinee tomorrow will record
it will decide tomorrow cuz like I said
I like to put some up every day so uh
we'll talk to you guys later and thanks
for stopping by
yes